welcome back to las vegas now the week
of christmas might be a busy one for a
lot of us
which is why nanny bobby is sharing a
fast recipe for homemade chicken
cacciatore check it out
oh hello happy holidays to all of you
well i'll tell you there's nothing i
like more than a
warm flannel shirt during the holidays
when the nights are so cold
and the days are crisp but still very
very cold
and what i love so much is that
even though we're not doing the
traditional holidays where we're running
to
office parties or everybody else's
holiday parties
we're still very very busy and why
because so many of us
are making we're crafting we're cooking
we're doing things at home that we've
never really done before and that's
really costing us a lot of time it's
time we love but nonetheless but today
what i have for you is a great
recipe that if you get behind in your
holiday
wrapping and making that when it comes
to dinner time i'm going to give you a
fun and easy way to make a great dinner
for whomever you're feeding
so what i'm making for you is a really
really quick
chicken cacciatore and it starts with
already cooked chicken i'll show you
that in a minute but first i'm starting
with the onions you can see just they're
very big pieces
and we're going to take those and put
them right into the pot
and start sweating them and so while
we're sweating the onions
let's cut the peppers
[Music]
so you may be wondering what's so quick
about this recipe
and the answer is it's the chicken the
chicken
is an already cooked chicken i've
already cut this one up
but i'm going to show you how easy this
is when they're already
cooked and refrigerated
you're just going to pull off
there's a leg there's another one
you're going to tear off the back
[Music]
well this is cooking up so beautifully
you can smell it it's great we're just
adding the garlic so it doesn't burn we
put it in right before
we put in all the other ingredients and
then we're going to throw in some
already sliced up mushrooms
they will um skinny
down they will sweat down on their own
in the sauce
and we're gonna add salt and pepper
about two teaspoons of salt
especially if you bought a chicken that
was not
seasoned you want to add some good
flavor
and a teaspoon of pepper to give it some
heat
and we're going to stir this around and
are you ready
here's where things get really easy and
fun we're going to take two
28 ounce cans of fire roasted chopped
tomatoes
into the pot
into the pot and to give it great
flavor we're going to add my favorite
that i use with everything the rayos
arabiata sauce which has got a lot of
spice and heat to it
so good right into the pot we're gonna
stir this around
and into the pot goes the chicken
we're gonna let it cook for about an
hour
just to get all the flavors to melt
together ready here we go
so now this is my favorite part about
having a garden out back
is i came out here and clipped some
rosemary oregano and basil to throw
into the chicken cacciatore
[Music]
and that's it everybody so easy
happy making whatever it is you're
making while you're home
this pairs nicely with a great glass of
red
italian wine served with a baguette
sliced up so you can dip into the sauce
eat your chicken
and no stress have a wonderful holiday
season everyone and remember
spread love like butter oh we're all
salivating in the studio
i like that one i think i can do that
one check out nanny bubby's kitchen and
garden on social media
and online at nannybubby.com we also
want to thank chapman automotive for
sponsoring the segment